so this this just happened like
literally as we were sitting down I was
like Mark milley traitor to the United
States when I'm slamming the table down
and then we're like oh Lydia's like
Nicki Minaj was suspended I was like oh
this takes precedence yes now um I don't
think it's necessarily more important
than Mark Milly a general calling China
and giving them warning about U.S you
know uh plans but I do think this is
significant one we're seeing a celebrity
for those that have been following Nicki
Minaj is tweeting about the vaccine
she's being lied about left and right in
the media and I think this is a major
what should I say um
what was that movie where the guy was in
the computer and then there were two
pills and one of them woke him up
whatever that was it's about a word I
can't say on this thing here no you can
say red pill so it's a major I was
making a joke it's a major red pill
moment for a lot of people to see Nicki
Minaj being like hey they're lying about
me she is married by the way all right
on Mrs Nicki Minaj and uh the same thing
happened with Kanye Kanye comes out and
says something reasonable and also the
media lies about everything so Kanye
came out I don't know if you guys saw
this and he was talking about the 13th
Amendment the 13th amendment allows
slavery in the event of a criminal
conviction and so Kanye was like we got
to do away with that and they were like
Kanye calls for reinstating slavery or
something and he's like dude like they
really go over the top with it so we
have this tweet I just picked up
whatever random verified Twitter user
who had tweeted about it okay who had
Nicki Minaj getting locked out of her
Twitter account after reposting a four
reposting Tucker Carlson on their 2021
bingo card and he won Nicki Minaj we got
some tweets from her
so see uh okay so uh Stephen Colbert's
show oh actually it looks like CNN
actually said this
all right we gotta slow down this is
this is this is a crazy story fast
developing Nicki Minaj tweeted that her
cousin didn't want to get the vaccine
because his friend got the vaccine and
his balls swole up and then he became
impotent and his fiance called off their
wedding
it's probably a ridiculous story I don't
think it's true I bet it is true it's
it's horribly hilarious okay but but but
true in the sense like did the vaccine
have anything to do all right that's no
that there's nothing on theirs like the
vaccine adverse event where they're like
my balls are huge like no so she tweeted
this thing out and the media then
started claiming here's what they said
in this uh CNN clip they said she cited
that reason as to why she's not getting
vaccinated which is not true now I gotta
say
I got I actually had uh let's say a
minor argument with the people with with
our friends over at timcast.com talking
about the article that was written up
because the original headline was like
Nicki Minaj says she won't get
vaccinated to attend the Met Gala or
something and then people were like
that's not a fair headline and I I don't
agree with the framing either and we
talked about it so here's what's true
Nicki Minaj said the Met Gala wants you
to get vaccinated if I'm gonna get
vaccinated it's not gonna be for the Met
Gala and so the headline used on timcast
was Nicki Minaj refuses to get vaccine
form at gala and I'm like
technically accurate yeah but I don't
like that because Nicki Minaj said that
the reason she's not traveling is
because she had a baby
and then she mentioned she's not getting
she's not going that the Met Gala wanted
the vaccines and if she was going to get
the vaccine it wouldn't be for them this
title I feel like makes it seem like she
didn't go to the Met Gala because she
didn't want to get vaccinated and so we
discussed it and it's like look the
headline is true she said she wouldn't
get vaccinated for them at gala like I
don't know what how else we should
friend like make a really long headline
and I'm like all right whatever I defer
to your judgment but some people in the
comments posted something and I'm like
good you know I'll let that be known my
thoughts Nicki Minaj won't punch a vax
ticket to attend Met Gala
punch a vax ticket yeah you know get
your backs done just say it you can
condense it there was a way to do it but
I hear what you're saying I guess the
issue is you need the proper context
yeah the reason she didn't go she stated
some before any of this controversy
somebody was like why haven't you done
an appearance in a year she was I just
had a baby I'm not traveling
then when they're like the Met Gala she
said they require of X-Men it I wouldn't
get it for them anyway but if you look
at the full context of what she's been
saying she didn't go not because of the
vaccine she even said she would get one
to go on tour she didn't go because
she's got a kid and she doesn't want to
travel oh so now they're claiming one of
the reasons she won't get vaccinated is
because she because of swollen testicles
Stephen Colbert did a whole bit this is
the crazy thing that people need to
understand when Sarah Palin was was you
know running with the with McCain
Tina Fey who I think Tina Fey is
brilliant did this bit where she's like
I can see Russia from my house
Sarah Palin ever said anything like that
that's ridiculous what Sarah Palin did
say was something like you know you know
in terms of foreign policy you can
actually see Russia from the westernmost
point of Alaska and we actually have to
negotiate with them on the straight on
trade so I think you know this is a
major benefit for the office of the
presidency and I'm like it's actually a
really great Point as governor of Alaska
you have that trade routes that goes
between the Bering Strait or whatever
and that means she has to work with
Russia what happens a bunch of my
friends are like oh man like Sarah Palin
thinks you can see Russia from her house
she's so I'm like dude that was that was
Tina Fey like that wasn't that wasn't
real and that's what we have going on
right now so now
because I think this is important for
one we got uh let me shout out some of
these people one person responded with
uh because because Nicki Minaj posted uh
Tucker Carlson and actually did I pull
that one up okay I don't have that one
she posted Tucker Carlson oh wait I do
have I do that yeah with a bullseye it's
a bullseye over Tucker Carlson's content
and Hassan the son says you know he's a
white nationalist right okay Tucker
Carlson is not a white nationalist
that's a lie
um and so Nicki Minaj responded to him
and other people saying like dude I can
point out when someone's telling the
truth that doesn't make me political or
whatever and then here's the crazy thing
when multiple news outlets lied about
like the swollen testicles thing she
said y'all are lying about me and people
started saying Nikki's on the side of
the far right so she you know she's
wrong
if you question the media you're far
right that's far right now yeah well
look Nikki Nikki is in trouble from the
jump you know why because she's Young
Money young money Lil Wayne Lil Wayne
Donald Trump yeah
yeah oh for real she's in Young Money
with with Drake and uh and Lil Wayne and
Nikki and it's very clear Lil Wayne is a
trump guy they're clearly on a different
tip whatever tip that is they're on
their own one and I thought it was
admirable actually what she said which
is that like I'm not traveling because I
have a baby and I may or may not get the
vaccine but I sure as heck aren't
getting the vaccine just to go to some
stupid party with some lady wearing tax
rich on her butt so to me I mean that
all adds up I do not listen to her music
I probably don't appreciate her value so
much but at the same time I can see how
her associations and her willingness to
question the narratives and her
willingness to just speak her mind
wasn't she the one that like saw like
her tax bill one day or whatever she's
just like going off on the taxes I mean
that all makes perfect sense to me these
are just things normal people say why is
she being singled out because she's got
millions and millions of followers
because yeah these are just random
thoughts man the media is a swamp of
full of well I don't know if piranhas
live in the swamps or like rivers in the
rainforest but it is a swamp somewhere
bad with some kind of swamp piranha and
if you uh uh you know look Nicki Minaj
comes out and she said
you know they don't they don't care
about anything she says until she said
pray on it and make the choice for
yourself as we often say and that is the
No-No the No-No phrase I mean look it
stop me if I go down the road I'm not
allowed to go down but the bottom line
for me is that I've come to understand
that this is a personal choice and
frankly
you know I don't know where this is
gonna go because you know I'm sensitive
to all these things because I don't want
to say the wrong thing I'm being
censored I'm censoring myself okay
that's Humanity you got to censor
yourself a little bit as you go the
point is it's like look it is it is a
personal decision that's now not being
allowed to be a personal decision and
that is pretty much the bottom line when
I when I think about it and I think
about whether or not I should do it for
myself or my kids should do it for
themselves
those are independent questions if
somebody is bullying me into doing it my
first instinct is just be like no I
think the vaccine mandates do that just
know I've seen tons of people tweeting
not because of the Mandate okay if
you're gonna spill the bottle tons of
people tweeting now because of the
Mandate never going anywhere near any of
this stuff yeah and you know the
response on the left is like well you
were never going to do it anyway and no
that's not true I wouldn't seriously
consider I have all of my vaccines I
just got a pertussis booster oh my right
like I had to do that when my kids were
being bored it's like your moms are the
mother-in-laws the moms they all had to
get a pertussis booster just to come in
and see the baby no one batted an eye at
that right here's here's the issue
when someone is like after 28 years of
research and we have this vaccine or
whatever or decades and then we've come
to a legislative decision after many
votes and many hearings on it that's the
key phrase legislative decision right
well when when I elect somebody and they
say we're going to have a hearing in the
you know senate committee on X and it's
having to do with vaccines I'm like
these are all normal processes that I
can watch on TV can hear the arguments
and then there's a vote on it and it's
put through a legislative process I'm
like you got it when there's when
there's long-term data and stuff so
here's my issue right now is a vaccine
mandate by decree get out of my face
well not playing well no no no no no
because you shut up Ian because I want
to let you finish your thoughts there's
no medical exemptions there's no
religious exemptions and now you can see
the government is giving exemptions only
when they're scared like to The Postal
Service no that's not true that was that
was that was debunked oh was it yeah
sorry but the nurses in New York they
were running short on nurses because
nurses were refused to get vaccinated
and then uh the courts reversed it so
okay if you're a medical worker you're
good now because they were like people
are quitting in this critical
infrastructure I'll put it this way
when someone's like we have a hundred we
have hundreds of years of data on like
polio and kids have like a 20 chance of
like disability and like by the time
you're 50 you know you're negatively
impacted and we have this vaccine fine
after a long period of time
that I get when an executive just comes
out and says it and we have no long-term
health effects or risk for for pregnancy
because the FDA insert doesn't include
it's like we don't have data on that I
can respect someone saying I'm gonna
wait you can't come to me and try and
get in between me and my doctor that's
my problem with this that it's like I I
honestly I think the vaccines are safe
you know I don't believe a lot of the
the the high you know stressed out
sensationalism you hear like swollen
balls or whatever I don't believe it
sorry I certainly think there can be
Adverse Events and some of them probably
rare and extreme don't get me wrong but
regardless I'm gonna do my research I'm
gonna go talk to my doctor what do we
have now leftists these people claiming
to be libertarian socialists or anything
but walking in between me and my doctor
and saying shut up don't listen to him
go get the vaccine and I'm like can you
get out of my way so I can ask this guy
like what he thinks because you know
Howard Stern comes out and he's like Joe
Rogan's doctors are [ __ ] for
prescribing him this medication and I'm
like Howard Stern you're not a doctor
how are we going to sit here and have
them say you're not a doctor you didn't
do research and then I'm like neither
did you
so when I when I tweeted
don't just pull into a parking lot go
talk to your doctor get him on the phone
ask him the questions you got to ask
them people were like why would you do
that you're scaring people I'm like yo
literally people on the left telling me
that I was wrong to suggest people talk
to their doctor
that's where we're at so a few things
there one the thing that comes to mind
first and foremost here is that there
was no legislative process
okay requiring all corporations of 100
employers or more to have their
employees be vaccinated sounds to me
like a law
right it is and a law should be
negotiated discussed debated in public
and voted upon by your representatives
that you send to Congress because it's
going to affect basically everybody 80
million people I think is what the
target was with that 100 million 100 and
uh and up incorporation I think they
said it'll affect 100 million 100
million great yeah so what if this is is
a prime example of the way that the
administrative State and the Judiciary
have stripped the legislation
legislature of all their power and
basically ended our democracy okay you
have administrative State executive
branch agencies that create a rule then
they they it basically becomes law then
somebody files a lawsuit and the judge
rules on whether or not that law is
right that is how or whether or not that
rule is right that is how laws are being
made in America today independent of the
legislature we do not have a democracy
that it is gone the Republic is gone yes
when the executive branch administrative
offices can make a rule someone can
protest it in the courts and the courts
rule on its validity and then it becomes
law that way that means our Republic is
dead it is dead it is gone it is history
and we now must move into a phase what
I've been calling now refound or die so
so what kind of government do we have
it's we have a technocracy it's it's not
a technocracy
um you know technocracy typically is a
reference to rule by technology right no
no no by technocrats by people who
believe they're experts in their field
that they can scientific method their
way to Perfection that they can resolve
all human conflict and issues if we just
try harder legislate harder administer
harder that's that's not what we have
well that's what the vaccine is it's a
piece of science technocracy is
typically reference to like you know a
rule by those of of of science Google
technology Facebook yeah
no no but Joe Biden making an OSHA rule
is in technocracy it's something else
it's it's akin to like so tyranny yes
let's let's break this down in the in
the classically liberal Democratic
fashion our government works uh as such
we we elect a representative for our
area they go and have a meeting where
they draft a bill say we want this to be
law that goes goes from their committees
into the greater chamber where they vote
on it and then the Executive Signs off
on it or vetoes it if there's a veto and
this is how Most states work and how the
federal government works if they veto it
then you need a greater majority in the
legislation to overrule him
here's how it works today the executor
the executive The Sovereign drafts a
rule to the people saying You must
comply and the people are are allowed
only if negative negatively impacted to
question that law and then the courts as
you mentioned will weigh as to whether
or not the negative impact is is
Justified is is would justify striking
down the executive decree that's very
very different from my representative
drafts a bill it goes to committee
there's a debate on it there's hearings
we're at the point right now where
Joe Biden has done this on more than one
occasion completely shutting out the
legislative judicial branches
Cuomo did the same thing so it's more of
you can argue that what we still get to
elect the president or whatever sure
fine but that doesn't change the fact
that we're not it's there's no Dem
there's no democracy when it when you
you appoint an a sovereign
it's basically electing a king is what
we're doing we're electing a king every
four years a guy that can just make
decrees he can make decrees that are
backed up by his minions and backed up
by the courts and the police and the
police it's uh it's really frustrating
and sad and scary if you want to really
learn about it look up Dr mourini this
guy has written in tremendous amount on
the administrative State and there's it
happens in every domain it happens in
education it happens in finance it
happens in healthcare it happens in
security it happens in policing it
happens everywhere
and it's just it's literally getting
worse each pres I don't know the SATs on
this but I'm I'm assuming this is right
each of the president is increasingly
using executive orders on top of to best
the guy before him more executive boards
more executive boards more executive
orders and with Congress at its stand
still there's no legislation one last
point on this when the legislator was
founded legislature was founded in
America they would the the details on
the laws would be like 600 tons of this
42 tons of that a thousand feet of this
10 miles of that they were as specific
as possible now it's just like you know
protect the workers and then let the
administrative State figure out how to
do that now it's uh disorderly conduct
it can be arrested for anything yeah the
cops can walk up and be like you're
being disorderly you're obstructing
justice thanks for checking out this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast if you
want to see the full show come back to
this channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time